so I've come to believe one critically
important truth our bodies are
constantly solving for reality even when
we're
[Music]
not so I came out of a season where I
was super anxious almost lost everything
right but I had everything at the same
time I had a great job I had a good
marriage I had healthy kids like so
everything was working except my body
was running and fighting everyone and
everything and then I remember landing
on a couple of days points that really
shook me more people in the United
States are under the care of a licensed
mental health professional right now
than ever before in human history and
more people are medicated for
psychological issues right now than ever
before in human history we've created a
world that our bodies cannot exist in so
the first logical question that
anybody's going to ask is okay well what
do I do now where do I start to build a
non- anxious life the place we have to
begin is with reality you must choose
reality so when we're little we get this
picture of what life is supposed to look
like or sometimes we get a picture of
what life should never look like all of
these stories are mapped inside of us
from a very young age and then we
graduate high school and we turn 23 25
30 35 and all of a sudden we stop one
day and realize our life looks nothing
like this fantasy that we had built when
we were young people treated you
differently cuz you were the wrong color
in the wrong part of town you didn't
love the right way you were kicked over
this way we're on the other side look at
all this money we're making I made
partner I got tenure I've got all these
certificates and
achievements and your kids want nothing
to do with you your wife has created a
life completely separate from you your
husband doesn't even know who you are
anymore whatever has happened in your
life there's a gap between what you
wanted to happen this life you imagin
this thing you're still aiming for
subconsciously and the life you actually
live Joo calls it extreme
ownership my buddy's dad called it
staring down the devil cuz you got to
look in the mirror and be honest about
your shortcomings honest about where
people hurt you you got to be honest
about your coping mechanisms and all of
that is brutal choosing reality is about
putting it all on the table the good the
bad the abuse all of it so we're going
to back up and we're going to pause and
we're going to take a deep breath and
we're going to
Exhale we're going to choose reality
where are we right
now that gap between what is and what we
so desperately hoped for and long for
but
isn't that Gap is
grief if you leave with one truth know
this there is no
life without
hurt you didn't think you were going to
owe this much money you didn't think you
were going to have to move you didn't
think that your marriage would be
hanging on by a thread you didn't think
she would leave
you and here we
are there is no path without
hurt you cannot go It
Alone our bodies aren't designed to
handle sadness and isolation our bodies
aren't designed to head into grief alone
and so choosing reality is about not
trying to deny the fact that you're
going to hurt you are and since you're
going to hurt you have to invite grief
along you got to invite the feelings
that associate with grief like sadness
disappointment
frustration and as great scientists have
found with sadness comes incredible
accuracy with disappointment with
frustration in the Smoke of what feels
like everything has burned to the
ground you can finally see clearly for
the first
time so we head into grief because on
the other side of grief there's boldness
strength action cuz my body is healing
cuz I've got people on either side of me
and in front of me and behind me I can
go defend and protect and walk ahead the
only path to a non-anxious life right
through the middle of
reality you have to take an honest
inventory of where you are
you got to measure it how's your
marriage how are your kids when's the
last time you went to a doctor and got a
blood workup when's the last time you
went to a dentist and I know you can't
afford it so how's your
money how much money do you
owe give any money in
savings or is Visa and MasterCard your
savings
plan all these things become a part of
you and your body's not going to let you
sleep your body's not going to let you
rest your body's not going to want you
to be intimate because it's trying to
survive she got to take an
inventory so over the last few years my
life has changed my family's life has
changed and so is my bank account so is
my friend Circle so is how much I'm on
the road and how little I'm sleeping so
I thought I would be the hero and I went
and called the local counselor who I
trust and I sat down and one one hour
turned into two and one counseling
session turned into the next week and
the next week and here I was finding
myself saying things that I had never
said out loud in my entire life in an
effort to tell everybody how to live a
non-anxious life I had created an
incredibly anxious one
myself and so this whole experience for
me went from telling how to have a
non-anxious life to pulling up a seat
next to you and saying let's figure this
thing out together but here's my
promise there's light on the other side
of this thing I'm sleeping better my
marriage is better I'm a better parent
I'm a better
friend but choosing reality that's your
starting line that's where we
[Music]
begin